[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
agè panierunaché bonjour Merci beaucoup
madame la ministre d'être avec nous
ministre de la transition énergétique on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régional représenté par Stéphane Vernet
de Ouest France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
Orian bonjour an bonjour bonjour on va
parler évidemment de vos dossiers ils
sont nombreux à espagner runché mais
d'abord un mot de l'actualité on l'a vu
hier soir en 4e jour de trêve ce sont
ces trois enfants français qui ont donc
été enfin libérés par le Hamas la trêve
a été prolongée de 2 jours est-ce que
vous savez si d'autres Français seront
libérés dans les prochaines heures
d'abord je veux dire mon immense
soulagement pour ces trois Français et
dire aussi que nous allons continuer à
agir amassablement diplomatiquement
jusqu'à ce que les cinq autres Français
qui sont aujourd'hui retenus en otage et
également l'ensemble des otages de
différentes nationalités que nous
n'oublions pas soit libéré je crois que
c'est notre responsabilité donc un
soulagement mais une joint en demi en
demi-teinte parce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup à faire que ce soit pour les
populations civiles de Gaza ou pour les
otages et l'espoir qu'il soit libéré
prochainement dans les dans les
prochaines heures en tout cas d'ici la
fin de la trêve bien sûr l'espoir est
toujours présent mais nous sommes
surtout concentrés sur notre action
diplomatique pour faire avancer les
choses un autre sujet d'actualité votre
collègue Olivier verrant était ti à
Crépol pour rencontrer la famille de
Thomas ce jeune de 16 ans qui a été tué
Olivier verrand il a dit que c'était un
drame qui nous fait courir le risque
d'un basculement de notre société vous
êtes d'accord avec ça je crois qu'en
tout cas ce drame il montre qu'il y a
des tensions qui sont inacceptables dans
la société et que nous devons absolument
agir avec autorité ce que nous faisons
avec fermeté mais également travailler
sur le vivre ensemble et c'est tout
l'enjeu du travail que nous menons
depuis les émeutes de juillet pour nous
cette page des émeutes elle ne s'est pas
tourné lorsqu'elles se sont terminées au
contraire nous pensons qu'il faut agir
dans l'école c'est ce que fait Gabriel
àal nous pensons qu'il faut agir avec
les forces de l'ordre c'est ce qu'on
fait en renforçant les forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qu'on fait aussi en les
déployant sur le terrain en proximité je
pense notamment aux plus de 200 brigades
de gendarmerie qui ont été déployé sur
le terrain ça c'est
un vrai changement par rapport aux
mandatures de François Hollande ou de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui avait replié ses
forces de proximité et c'est ce que nous
faisons avec la justice avec Éric Dupont
meriti qui déploie une justice de
proximité qui doit être rapide et qui
doit porter mais c'est suffisant pour
éviter un basculement on a vu les
réactions politiques après ce drame de
crpol on a vu les représailles avec ses
ministes d'extrême droit qui sont allés
je je regrette que certains font leur
miel de ce type d'épisode et qui souffle
sur les
flammes du conflit au sein de notre
société et avec un agenda clientéliste
électoral à peine transparent on peut
les nommer l'extrême droite l'extrême
gauche qui ne prennent pas leur
responsabilité dans ce type de situation
là où nous nous agissons je rappelle que
ce sont les mêmes qui ne votent pas qui
ne votent pas les projets de loi qui
nous permet aujourd'hui de remettre des
juges des greffiers des policiers des
gendarmes et de renforcer l'autorité
dans l'éducation nationale on parle de
vos dossiers on commence par le
nucléaire Stéphan et oui vous serez à
l'inauguration officielle du salon
mondial du nucléaire civile juste après
l'émission il s'ouvre à Paris pour pour
3 jours alors comment comment se porte
la filière nucléaire française c'est
mieux notre notre parc nucléaire est-ce
qu'il a été remis en état par rapport à
l'année dernière ah on le voit
aujourd'hui nous avons plus de 40
réacteurs qui sont aujourd'hui connectés
au réseau nous sommes structurellement
exportateurs d'électricité à nouveau à
nouveau depuis le début de l'année donc
effectivement nos réacteurs existants
fonctionnent mieux mais ce qui est
surtout très Enour com à l'arrêt il y a
combien de réacteurs à l'arrê 41
réacteurs qui fonctionnent 15 réacteurs
à
l'arrêt et ça c'est normal c'est ve dire
que tous les réacteurs ne fonctionnent
pas en permanance c'est tout à fait
logique et la difficulté que nous avions
l'année dernière de corrosion sous
contrainte est en trîn d'être réparé
progressivement à un rythme industriel
qui nous permet d'être confiant sur le
passage de l'hiver je vais être très
clair le passage de l'hiver nous sommes
confiants nous allons continuer à faire
des efforts de sobriété parce que c'est
bon pour la planète et c'est bon pour la
facture des Français mais effectivement
nous sommes en bien meilleure posture
que l'année dernière ensuite sur le
nucléaire moi je trouve que c'est très
encourageant parce qu'on voit que non
seulement EDF avance dans ses projets
dans évidemment la maintenance du parc
existant mais dans la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs dans l'avancement
d'un projet d'un projet de SMR c'est un
petit réacteur modulaire de génération
suivante qui va permettre aussi
d'élargir l'ensemble des solutions qu'on
qu'on peut proposer pour produire de
l'électricité compétitive et bacarbone
mais nous accompagnons des start-ups si
nouvell start-up vous avez dévoilé hier
que j'ai annoncé hier qui sont sur des
technologies nouvelles de fusion donc de
réutilisation du combustible ou à usage
de chauffage donc on le voit la filière
est en forme elle produit elle se
construit elle crée de l'emploi et notre
grand sujet aujourd'hui c'est de devoir
mettre en place les formation parce que
nous allons devoir recruter 100000
100000 personnes dans les 10 ans qui
viennent et il faut avoir des personnes
formées on sera dans les temps par
rapport à vos objectifs on aura vraiment
des des petits réacteurs nucléaires made
in France en en 2030 ou on va être
obligé d'acheter du matériel américain
alors je crois qu'onachètera pas du
matériel américain moi je suis très
consciante sur la capacité de notre
filière à industrialiser ses solutions
mais surtout je le rappelle nous sommes
un des rares pays au monde à être
capable de construire un réacteur de A à
Z euh il compris un petit réacteur de
nouvelle génération il compris un petit
réacteur de nouvelle génération je l'ai
indiqué nous soutenons six nouveaux
réacteurs nous avons EDF qui est assez
avancé sur la construction d'un réacteur
nuvarde et j'ai déjà soutenu deux
premiers rcteurs donc nous avons neuf
projets de réacteurs petits réacteurs
modulaires nouvelles génération qui sont
aujourd'hui diff à des stades plus ou
moins avancés hein certains sont
vraiment encore euh du du du labo vers
le prototype d'autres en revanche sont
proches de l'industrialisation donc
notre filière et une des meilleures du
monde si ce n'est la meilleure du monde
on vous pose la question parce que cette
nouvelle technologie on on on sent on
pressent qu'elle sera indispensable pour
développer la production d'hydrogène
vert à grande échelle euh en France
comment faire sans ces ces petits
réacteurs o où en est le plan hydrogène
qui avait été annoncé en 2020 là aussi
vous vous tiendrez les objectifs oui
nous nous avons un plan hydrogène qui se
déploie sur les territoires il y a des
dizaines de projets qui sont aujourd'hui
soutenus pour construire des
électrolyseurs je pense à genvia par
exemple à Bézier je pense au projets
dans le dans le Grand Est nous avons
également euh des projets d'utilisation
d'hydrogène vert pour décarboner nos
industriels j'étais encore la semaine
dernière avec Roland liscur le ministre
en charge de l'Industrie pour signer des
contrats avec les grands industriels qui
émettent du CO2 je pense à l'acier je
pense à l'aluminium je pense au ciment
et qui vont avoir besoin d'hydrogène
vert et eux investissent pour récupérer
cet hydrogène bac carbone et nous
déployons aujourd'hui non seulement plus
de nucléaire mais plus aussi d'énergie
renouvelable car l'hydrogène bacarbone
que nous allons utiliser il est sur base
hydrog est sur base nucléaire ou sur
base renouvelable et dernier point avec
mon collègue Roland lescur je serai le 5
décembre prochain euh à l'inauguration
de de syimbio et nous annoncerons la
prochaine euh mise à jour de notre
stratégie nationale hydrogène et
notamment des dispositifs de soutien
pour permettre aux industriels
d'utiliser de l'hydrogène vert et de se
passer de ce qu'on appelle l'hydrogène
gris c'est-à-dire l'hydrogène qui est
produit à partir d'énergie fossile on va
on va on va venir au renouvelable mais
juste que vous parliez de la
construction de nouveau réacteur on en
est où de le P de Flamanville est-ce que
vous avez un calendrier de mise en route
2024 vous savez que nous sommes
maintenant désormais en phase de test
2024 prier trimestre 2024 Auton
2024 et nous sommes en phase de test
aujourd'hui moi ce qui compte pour moi
c'est qu'à la fin d'année 2024 le
réacteur de flamandville soit connecté à
100 % tout à fait juste une dernière
question sur l'électricité vous disiez
on est confiant pour pour l'hiver le le
PDG de de DF Luc bremmont dit la même
chose confiance même s'il faut rester
vigilant du coup si si la la production
est est suffisante les les les planètes
bien alignées pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
que pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé
de mener une une une expérience qui
viserait à brider les les les compteurs
de la puissance électrique de
200000 foyers parce que moi j'anticipe
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à une
transformation en profondeur de notre
système énergétique nous allons devoir
augmenter notre production d'électricité
massivement nous allons en avoir besoin
pour baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre remplacer le pétrole
remplacer le charbon dans les années qui
VI
et plutôt que de me laisser surprendre
en phase de crise puisque finalement
nous sommes aperçus que personne n'avait
travaillé réellement sur ce système de
de délestage et n'avait prévu la manière
de le faire nous avons mis un dispositif
en place nous n'avons pas eu à l'utilisé
l'année dernière et c'est heureux mais
il faut toujours préparer les crises et
ce dispositif sur lequel nous
travaillons qui est un test qui est de
se dire au fond plutôt que de couper
l'électricité sur chez les gens si on a
un problème de tension pourquoi nous
tout ça simplement ne pas baisser la
tension chez eux ce qui leur permet de
continuer à charger leur portable avoir
l'électricité à surtout avoir leur
frigidaire qui fonctionne ou leur
congélateur mais plus de chauffage
pendant pendant he alors pas plus de
chauffage nécessairement mais par
exemple plus la machine à laver ou le
four micro-ondde qui fonctionne en même
temps ça sécurise les gens et nous ça
nous permet d'avoir une mesure
supplémentaire de notre boîte à outils
en cas de tension sur les réseaux et les
tensions sur les réseaux ça peut arriver
en cas de de problèm de production
générale mais ça peut arriver tout
simplement si vous avez un post source
qui a une difficulté technique ça c'est
des choses qui arrive mais est-ce que
vous êtes confiante au point de dire au
français il y aura pas de blackout cet
hiver mais il n jamais été question
qu'il y ait un blackout un blackout je
rappelle que c'est un effondrement
généralisé de notre système électrique
nous ne sommes pas le Texas
effectivement aux États-Unis il y a des
risques de blackout il y en a eu en
France avec le travail du gouvernement
nous nous sommes précisément mis en
situation de ne pas avoir de blackout
aujourd'hui a lieu une conférence sur
les prix de l'énergie ce sera cet
après-midi vous réunirez des
parlementaires des élus locaux pour
faire le point sur les tarifs de
l'électricité du gaz du pétrole est-ce
que les Français peuvent espérer voir
leur facture d'énergie baissé alors la
promesse que nous tenons aujourd'hui
c'est de faire en sorte que les français
payent la réalité de leur coût de
l'électricité c'est ce que j'ai porté au
niveau européen avec une négociation
historique où nous avons eu gain de
cause face notamment à l'Allemagne qui
ne souhaitait pas
reconnaître l'énergie nucléaire comme
étant sur le même pied d'égalité que les
énergies renouvelaable ça nous l'avons
fait le 17 octobre tout le monde nous
disait c'est impossible vous n'y
arriverez pas nous l'avons fait nous
l'avons fait avec le président de la
République et la deuxième chose c'est la
négociation que j'ai mené avec EDF et et
Bruno Le Maire pour préparer la suite de
ce qu'on appelle la reine qui est une
régulation qui permet aujourd'hui au
français d'avoir une partie de leur
facture qui est fondée sur les coûts du
du nucléaire tout en étant exposé et on
l'a vu l'année dernière malheureusement
et de manière trop importante au prix du
marché avec cette nouvelle régulation ce
ne sera plus le cas puisque dès que le
BRI euh passera l'équivalent de 110 €
d'argent d'aujourd'hui alors nous
prélèverons sur EDF tout le complément
de recettes que obtiendrait EDF dans
dans le paiement de ces factures et nous
le redonnerons au consommateurs de façon
à ce qu'il ne cet élément d'augmentation
des prix ne pèse pas mais concrètement
sur leur fracture parce que là le prix
de l'électricité il est annoncé à la
hausse pour l'année prochaine alors euh
peut-être remettre les choses en
perspective nous on a très clairement
dit et je le redis la le prix de la
facture il doit évoluer en fonction de
la réalité des coûts de l'électricité de
notre mix électrique des coûts de notre
système nucléaire des coûts de de de nos
réseaux c'est ce que nous faisons et
c'est ce que nous allons faire l'année
prochaine et on l'a dit très clairement
avec Bruno Le Maire les augmentations DL
rentes de facture c'est terminé au
maximum la facture augmentera de 10 % ça
c'est très clair sur l'augmentation du
1er février 2024 et après je vois que le
Sénat souhaite augmenter la fiscalité
sur la facture ce qui est un autre
propos c'est pas le cûp de l'électricité
en propre c'est la question de la
fiscalité ça c'est une discussion
budgétaire qui est en cours je ne suis
pas sûre qu'il faille comme le propose
le Sénat comme l'a voté le scénat hier
augmenter de 20 % la fiscalité sur la
facture de l'électricité mais ça c'est
autre chose sans bouclier ça
augmenterait de 20 % le gouvernement
souhaite un bouclier pour le limiter à
10 % juste pour tout le monde mais le
Cénat juste juste le bouclier
énergétique euh protègera au maximum à
10 % ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
mettre plus de taxes sur l'électricité
mais le
Sénat voilà le Sénat dit c'est c'est pas
grave que les les Français les plus
aisés paye leur facture 20 % de plus en
revanche il faut protéger les plus
modestes et faire des moi j'aimerais
savoir ce que c'est que les Français les
plus aisés je rappelle que aujourd'hui
le revenu médien en France il est 1700 €
par mois je ne suis pas sûre qu'à 1700 €
par mois vous soyez aisé donc je pose
cette question très simplement je
comprends la logique du Sénat mais 20 %
d'augmentation de la facture ça me
paraît déraisonnable d'une manière
général on peut dire qu'on est rentré
dans un monde où le tout le prix de
l'énergie les prix de l'énergie que soit
carburant gaz électricité et cetera
toutes sources d'énergie a augmenté et
ne baissera plus est-ce que nos
entreprises sont alors je je vais
m'inscrire en faux contre ça regardez
les évolutions récentes le prix du
carburant est en train de baisser le
prix du gaz a baissé par rapport à
l'année dernière et le prix de
l'électricité qui avait atteint des
sommets sur les marchés internationaux
est en train de rerentrer le la rivière
rentre dans son lit ce qui nous permet
nous de lever le bouclier électricité
l'année prochaine puisque nous n'aurons
plus à compenser l'écart entre le prix
plafonné que nous avons mis pour les
Français et ce prix délirant que nous
devions payer sur les marchés il y a pas
de il y a pas de fatalité ça non il n'y
a pas de fatalité et puis surtout si on
veut baisser le prix de l'énergie en
fait il faut agir et c'est ce que nous
faisons agir c'est baisser notre
consommation d'énergie et c'est
augmenter notre production d'énergie
décarbonée aujourd'hui nous sommes
dépendants à 99 % des ortation de
pétrole 99 %. nous ne décidons pas des
prix du pétrole si nous voulons demain
ne plus avoir à subir les augmentations
de prix du carburant il faut produire
notre propre carburant en quelque sorte
notre propre carburant c'est
l'électricité l'électricité ça coûte
trois fois moins cher que le pétrole
dans un plein de voiture et ce que nous
portons avec le gouvernement le
président de la République et la
première ministre c'est d'avoir des
solutions d'accès à des voitures
électriques qui soient réellement à des
prix
à la portée du portefeuille des Français
moyens et des Français modestes avec le
bonus écologique que je souhaite
renforcer avec la prime à la conversion
ou avec le dispositif de leasing à 100
€. ça ce sont des solutions concrètes et
une fois que les Français seront équipé
de ces voitures derrière ils
économiseront du carburant puisque vous
savez que par année d'utilisation d'une
voiture électrique je parle d'une petite
voiture électrique un modèle type C3 ou
R5 c'est un peu près 1000 à 1200 €
d'économie chaque année c'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait pour les Français
vous avez du mal à convaincre le grand
grand public de ça je vous pose la
question parce qu'on a vu que votre
votre ministère était partenaire d'uneun
grande campagne de pub qui s'appelle
joule en électrique qui vise justement à
convaincre les les Françaises et les
Françaises de s'équiper de de véhicules
électriques oui tout à fait parce que il
y a beaucoup de fake news qui circulent
il y a une première fake news qui
consiste à expliquer que la voiture
électrique serait plus polluante que la
voiture thermique alors ça il suffit de
se tourner vers les experts ce n'est pas
moi qui le dit évidemment ce sont les
experts scientifiques vous pouvez le
prendre comme vous voulez une voiture
électrique est de à 5 fois moins
polluante qu'une voiture thermique sur
le cycle de vie c'est-à-dire non
seulement la production mais également
le temps d'utilisation de cette voiture
lorsqu'on roule avec ça c'est une
première chose qui est importante la
deuxième chose c'est que la voiture
électrique il y a encore 1 an 2 ans avec
des prix inaccessibles pour les 3/4 des
Français qui peut se payer aujourd'hui
une voiture neuve à plus de 40000 €
c'est inaccessible heureusement on
commence à voir sortir en Europe et en
France des modèles qui sont encore chers
y compris des modèles construits en
France par compris des des modèles
construits en France je pense évidemment
à la R5 qui sortira l'année prochaine
qui se rapproche en terme de prix de
prix un peu plus acceptable et qui avec
le bonus écologique et la prime à la
conversion vont arriver dans une zone
entre 10000 et 15000 € tout le monde ne
peut pas se payer une voiture neuve
entre 10000 et 1500 € mais c'est pas la
même chose que 40000 € et surtout quand
ces voitures elles-mêm
rejoindront le marché de l'occasion dans
3 4 5 ans alors elles sont réellement
accessibles au tout venant et ça c'est
c'est essentiel je juste dire que en
Norvège 80 % des immatriculations
aujourd'hui sont en électrique donc ce
qu'on nous disait impossible il y a
quelques années est en train de se
réaliser à nous d'en tirer le maximum
moi je veux travailler pour les Français
donc je travaille pour leur pouvoir
d'achat je travaille aussi pour leur
emploi ce que nous faisons avec la
voiture électrique c'est de déployer des
emplois autour de toute la chaîne de
valeur électrique les les gigafactory de
batterie électrique dans le nord de la
France dans le Pas de cané c'est des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois autour de
de ces voitures électriques donc un tout
l'argent mais tout l'argent que nous
investissons il la vocation à revenir en
France en Europe pour créer de l'emploi
et pour créer des sites un mot sur une
autre campagne gouvernementale elle a
été lancée cette fois par votre collègue
Christophe Béchu pour inciter les
Français à la sobriété avec des
dévendeur qui incite à ne pas
surconsommer à ne pas acheter du neuf
mais plutôt à recycler ça a pas plu à
Bruno LEM maire euh qui défend le
commerce et dit ne pas croire à la
culpabilisation du consommateur vous
êtes plutôt le maire ou plutôt Béchu
alors moi j'aime pas quand on pose le
sujet comme ça parce que la réalité
c'est que cette campagne elle a
peut-être un tort euh c'est dans un de
ces spots ça se passe dans un ce qui
pourrait apparaître comme un petit
commerce de centre-ville et on sait
combien on se bat dans le gouvernement
pour maintenir ces commerces dans nos
centrre-villees qui sont menacés
notamment par les plateformes mais poser
la question du réemploi poser la
question de la réparation ce sont des
bonnes questions ce sont des bonnes
questions pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français euh aller faire
réparer un un un un équipement ménager
pour quelques dizaines d'euros plutôt
que payer quelques centaines d'euros
pour le remplacer c'est une bonne
question et c'est emploi pour les
Français à nouveau ces équipements
ménagers on en produit très peu en
France par contre on les répare en
France et donc c'est cette vision que
nous portons avec Christophe béchus
c'est moi qui ai fait de la sobriété je
crois un élément important du débat
public et on a vu combien les les
Français ont adhéré les Français ils
nous disent pas je veux me priver mais
ils disent je ne veux pas gaspiller je
ne veux pas utiliser unutilement des
ressources dont je n'ai pas besoin donc
aidez-moi à avoir une consommation qui
finalement combine mon portefeuille et
un impact réduit sur la planète Stéphane
on parle des assises de l'économie de la
mer c'est organisé par West France oui
West France le marin le cluster maritime
ce c'est à Nant ça commence demain vous
serez vous serez présente pour lancer
les débats publics sur la planification
de l'éolien marin est-ce que vous vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus et de
quoi s'agit-il et quel est l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est que pour produire plus
d'électricité et de l'électricité
abondante
et compétitive en prix accessible en
prix nous avons besoin de l'éolien marin
l'éolien marin c'est une des énergies
qui dans son mode de fonctionnement en
terme de facteur de charge en gros ça
fonctionne quasiment tout le temps et de
puissance se rapproche le plus du du
nucléaire et surtout c'est très
compétitif en prix et donc notre
objectif dans les 10 ans qui viennent
c'est de faire en sorte de lancer
l'équivalent d'une vingtaine de nouveaux
parcs et en marin de façon à ce qu'on
puisse avoir de l'électricité pas cher à
partir de 2030 on en est où pour
l'instant il y a le parc olien de de
saint-nazer 80 éolienne qui marche
depuis un an ensuite saint-briux qui est
en train de exactement en nous allons
avoir féquan qui va venir ensuite dans
la foulée donc quasiment un parc éolien
marin connecté par année et notre
objectif c'est de passer à deux parcs
éoliens connecté simplement ce qu'on est
en train de faire c'est qu'on accélère
c'est-à-dire on organise face à faade
maritime par façade maritime il y a la
Méditerranée il y a le Nord il y a
Bretagne Sud Bretagne Nord Atlantique
d'un côté enfin vous représentez la
carte de France donc façade maritime par
façade maritime une discussion avec tout
le monde autour de la table les pêche
difficulté c'est de trouver des
emplacements qui fassent consensus les
pêcheurs les communes l'ensemble des
collectivités locales les transporteurs
aussi tous ceux qui ont besoin de la mer
qui utilisent la mer pour définir les
meilleures zones et puis il faut
évidemment prendre en compte la
biodiversité c'est ce que nous faisons
aussi et lorsqu'on aura cette
planification en pensant 2050 et en
regardant pas juste les prochains parcs
parce que votre objectif c'est 50 parcs
d'ici 2050 d'ici 2050 ESS de projeter où
on pourra les mettre de façon à
anticiper et à régler ces problèmes
d'acceptabilité notre retard parce que
le grand paradoxe c'est qu'on a toute la
filière tous les savoir-faire tout ce
qu'il faut pour produire de l'éolien mer
mais on est très peu avancé par rapport
à d'autres pays not on est moins avancé
que d'autres pays là on est en train de
rattraper hein je l'ai indiqué unact un
parc connectés chaque année de parcs à
partir des années 2030 mais moi mon
objectif il est très clair c'est de
lancer un très gros Appel d'offre à la
suite de cette concertation qui
permettra de préciser où nous pouvons
poser des parcs éolien en mer et
notamment où nous pouvons les poser de
manière rapide puisqu'on a besoin de
production rapide
de pouvoir lancer ce méga appel d'offre
en
2025 de façon à ce que les opérateurs
les fournisseurs d'énergie investissent
massivement soutiennent notre filière de
production et qu'on donne de la
visibilité à tout le monde et une
dernière question Stéphane une question
dans l'actualité la COP 28 démarche
jeudi vous vous y rendrez avec le
président de la République tout à fait
quelles sont les positions les ambitions
françaises que vous allez défendre au
cours de ce sommet les ambitions
françaises elles s'articulent autour de
de deux sujets c'est c'est le
financement comment on revoit en
profondeur le financement du du climat
par rapport au développement et c'est ce
que le président de la République a
porté au mois de juin dans le sommet
qu'il a organisé avec des dizaines de
pays pour justement moderniser la
manière dont la Banque Mondiale le FMI
les banques multilatérales de
développement et et et les pays
interviennent pour développer des
projets dans les pays en développement
les protéger du changement climatique ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point c'est la sortie des fossiles la
sortie des fossiles c'est notamment un
effort sur le charbon puisque nous nous
estimons qu'il faut là aussi respecter
les indications des scientifiques nous
sortirons du charbon avant 2030 c'est ce
que nous disent les scientifique pour
tenir la trajectoire du 1 de5 et nous
voulons que tous les pays en
responsabilité puissent s'organiser pour
faire de même qu'on arrête de développer
de nouveaux projets de centrale à
charbon mais il faut pas oublier le gaz
et le P
c'est une sortie organisée sur ces
énergies fossiles on peut pas le faire
du jour au lendemain mais plus on
anticipe et plus on se donne des
trajectoires moins ça coûtera au
citoyens merci merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité merci Stéphane la de
Ouest France et Gaza on a regarde trois
jeunes otages francoisraélien libéré
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Stéphane on passe au club des
territoires